all right so seven popular twitch
streamers living in one five bedroom
house in a gated community in Austin
Texas what could possibly go wrong well
from rampant uncollected [ __ ] dead
cockroaches noise complaints general
degenerate behavior and an eviction a
whole hell of a lot apparently
okay so what are we talking about here
back in May a bunch of twitch streamers
including pink sparkles Kay bubbles
Mitch Jones D cane and others moved into
a streaming house with the goal of
creating a content driven community on
paper it's pretty normal idea there are
gaming houses for eSports teams and
there are countless examples of YouTube
and twitch personalities having houses
that serve as home bases for their
streams do you love yourself but an
execution things went bad fast as in 48
hours fast 2 days after moving into this
gated community the address of this
house full of streamers was leaked
online and somebody from the outside
lodged a complaint with the local
Housing Association and before we get
into this this complaint and everything
it says is alleged and the score eSports
has not been able to independently
verify it hi
I am writing to you because I saw a
house in your neighborhood and the
address was leaked to the internet into
thousands of people and I was one of
them you have seven people living in a
five bedroom house live streaming people
underage drinking partying doing drugs
etc pretty much engaging in degenerate
activity and now thousands of people
have seen it and know where the houses
some of the girls sell naked photos
online and engage in sex work on the
side one of your tenants Mitchell Jones
has trashed so many properties prior to
this one I'm not really sure how he's
allowed on the lease they moved in two
days ago and this address got leaked to
people who will probably call the SWAT
team to that house and do all kinds of
stuff that will scare the neighbors and
endanger everyone this prompted the
association associated with the property
to begin looking into the situation
which ultimately led to eviction
proceedings now according to various
documents which pink sparkles first
posted to Twitter and then later deleted
the gang received their first letter
which kicked off the eviction
proceedings on May 15th the notice says
that everyone living there is in
violation of the declaration of
covenants conditions and restrictions
specifically section 4 which states in
three different ways that the house is
supposed to be used for single family
residents only for example all property
owned by the Association shall be
improved and used solely for
single-family residential use guests and
servant quarters are permitted now there
are two important things to take away
from this initial letter one is the
obvious emphasis on the single-family
residence which if described accurately
in the lease they all signed is a
potential legal problem and two
when the Sam hell still has servants
quarters in 2019 we are the TAM haters
we traveled all the way back through
town to call you a cracker but on May
12th before the group has ever served
their first eviction notice there are
already issues cropping up pink sparkles
posted a twit longer explaining that her
roommates would consistently come home
between 4:00 to 6:00 a.m.
drunk as [ __ ] causing a general ruckus
with their IRL streams and causing her
to lose out on sleep then on May 17th
the gang received another notice which
we pulled this important tidbit from in
addition to being in direct violation
the tenants are also breaking this very
lease in section 12 which states
exceeding the number of individuals who
are living in the home and conducting an
e-commerce business which they are being
compensated for and thus qualifies as a
business which the lease specifically
prohibits the notice also basically says
that hey if you don't comply with this
our shark eyed dolphin smiling lawyers
are going to find the homeowner and sue
you into oblivion you better lawyer up
[ __ ] because I'm not coming back for
30% I'm coming back now according to
text messages between pink sparkles and
the community representative the
homeowner has been scheduled for July
29th meeting with the homeowners
association the implication being that
she's going to be forced to evict them
regardless of whether or not she pays
the fine in the text thread sparkles
writes that basically the group should
go their separate ways for the sake of
the homeowner that was a lot of legal
nonsense we haven't even gotten to the
dog [ __ ] yet and yeah there was a dog
and it's [ __ ] everywhere there's a turd
right there there's a turd right there
there's a turd right there
there's turds everywhere and it
continued to [ __ ] everywhere when nobody
cleaned it up including mints Jones oh
look another turd right over there the
dog also reportedly [ __ ] inside of a
tide pod box I mean was this the only
place for the dog to go did the dog open
the tide box or was this was this
already in use I mean cats yeah makes
sense they [ __ ] in litter boxes but dogs
they usually [ __ ] outside
this dog was [ __ ] inside you know
what literally happened somebody reached
in so that this actually happened yeah
this actually happened somebody went to
do their laundry reached inside the tide
pod box and found some dog [ __ ]
who does that I guess this dog dies like
this is just not how I want to live my
life yo thank you very much for this up
you appreciate that [ __ ] look I'm not in
agreement with this probably rich old
white gated community who have nothing
better to do than fester over there
NIMBYism gated community [ __ ] but at
the same time if you owned a house in
the block you'd probably be pissed off
to having to constantly smell [ __ ]
and the hard-partying youths who record
everything they do and who have no
[ __ ] concept of sleep it's a little
like piece of [ __ ] dog on June 4th a
third and final notice was delivered to
the gang that basically mimics the first
two and as much as it says hey you
hooligans it's time to pack your [ __ ]
and get out while also introducing a few
new wrinkles based on the violations
noted in the previous letter quote
failure to cure this violation within
seven days from the date of this notice
will result in a fine to be assessed
against your account and the account in
this case is just for the homeowner the
notice also mentions that the homeowner
is potentially on the hook for any legal
fees if the Association decides to move
forward with a lawsuit this brings us to
right now where according to a video
from asthma gold whose pink sparkles is
boyfriend and a well-known Wow streamer
both pink sparkles and a few other
people in the house are currently
looking for new places to live no I took
them out to look at apartment a couple
of days ago or actually about a week ago
so this has already happened he also
defended pink sparkles after other
members of the house sounded off on her
for allegedly throwing them under the
bus to their landlord there's assertion
that she got them kicked out of the
house that's not true the second day
that they were there people started
calling the HOA and all of these people
started harassing them because the
address was leaked and as soon as that
happened the HOA began proceedings to
try to evict them from the house on day
two so to me this smacks of a few things
for one thing I think that we forget
that just because these personalities
spend hours in front of the camera
command sizable audiences and often make
lots of money from those audiences
they're often in their mid 20s or even
younger and when you're in your prime
partying years living in a house full of
other people who want to get down [ __ ]
is gonna get wild should they have
abided by the rules they tried to set up
early on that's a good idea when you're
living in a house full of other people
but also maybe think twice about renting
a giant mansion behind a gated community
full of rich stuffy old white people
just a thought I honestly believe that
this Community Association was looking
for any reason to kick out this group of
twenty year olds who were [ __ ] up the
neighborhood and the group potentially
violating the single family residence
part of their lease was their legal leg
to stand on
also if you keep it down all right yeah
there was a dog and yeah the dog [ __ ]
everywhere and that dog [ __ ] everywhere
and continue to I don't know if I can do
this